in one word in just one word join us
what is your professional style intense
i'm here with jonas Falk who is the
founder and CEO of organic life and
organic life basically feeds school kids
in Chicago we do we we serve about 3
million kids healthy school lunches
every single day in the Chicagoland area
so how did you get into that is kind of
an unusual thing to start right out of
school I was always into restaurants and
food service you know my family doesn't
take vacations to sightsee we take
vacations to eat and all we plan is you
know what's for lunch after breakfast
and what's for dinner after lunch and so
I went to a Michigan State to study
hotel restaurant management and i wrote
my business plan for my healthy school
lunch program i was going to build and
and our food service management company
that was going to do great things in the
school field how did it die to the paper
due they were gotta d it was probably
more result of my writing than the
actual paper because the plan obviously
is working and so what you do is you go
out and you bid on contracts said let's
say I'm Michael high school inc right or
whatever exactly and I have you know
what a couple thousand students and you
would come to me and you would do what
well there's actually a bid process it's
a federal bid and so competitors will
line up and and you'll tour the school
and see the grounds and you'll put
together your comprehensive proposal for
what we're going to do for the school
and we built the program that sets us
apart from our competitors to put a more
restaurant oriented food service
cafeteria in the school so if you were
providing the meals to my school and I
was a student what could I look forward
to eating Oh every day you'd have an
option of eight or ten restaurant
quality stations from our viva burrito
or mexican chipotle like station to
vietnamese sushi station greek-american
pizzeria the works the kids have choices
every day and this is all healthy this
is all healthy everything's good from
scratch we don't use any frozen foods
canned foods everything's processed you
know for the last 30 or 40 years and we
just said we're going to bring real
chefs in who know how to cook and we're
going to make everything from scratch
now how can you do that and compete on
price I mean you mentioned some your
competitors you should tell our viewers
you're competing isn't big big big
billion-dollar companies or who we
compete against every day I just think
our model was more to bring chefs in who
know how to cook and we banked on the
fact that more kids were going to come
in to eat every single day if the food
is great and so it was a risk we took
but generally we see about twice the
amount of kids eaten all of our
contracts as opposed to our competitors
and that's where we're able to keep our
prices down and keep sue your friend has
to be good or else your business doesn't
succeed exactly every day it has to be
good otherwise kids don't line up and
our business model doesn't work how do
you do that with quality controlled
usually are you like to give a mystery
shopper or a mystery student that comes
in and orders kids kids will tell you if
it was not good you'll hear right away
you know complaints or something you
hear every day in the restaurant
business no news is good news and so we
were pretty adept at keeping it pace
with what the kids want how many schools
are you in there weren't about 400
schools in the state only in Illinois
only in Illinois although this year
works panning out to some neighboring
states of Illinois Ohio Indiana
Wisconsin so if I if we were sitting
down here in five years where would you
like to be where would you nationwide
nationwide that's the plan to keep
moving the brand and our philosophy and
serving great food to kids all over the
country Jennifer you'll have a minute or
so left so if you had any advice for
somebody who was you know wanted to
start a business and you start a fairly
successful one at a very young age what
would that advice be what was the sort
of the biggest thing that you didn't
know then that you know now I would say
don't think you know we didn't know a
lot of things when we first got started
but we knew what we wanted to do and you
just have to go for it if you think
about all the roadblocks you're never
going to get started you just need to go
for it and keep at it and things will
work